[Music]
what are you looking for
chest hairs is there any chance i'll hit
puberty in the next few weeks
oh god i hope not why the campus is so
big i'll never make it from one class to
another without a solid dose of
testosterone
maybe they'll let you leave early so
you'll have time but the end of the
class is when i point out the teacher's
mistakes
everybody loves that i'd say run across
campus but i know how you feel about
sweating
it's the urine of the skin why not ride
your bike
i considered that but i can't let my
colleagues see me with training wheels
they'll think i'm a child can't have
that
see any fuzz growing let me look
what do you want i was hoping you could
help me build up my leg muscles to
increase my speed
if you don't want people chasing you'd
be less annoying it's so i can get to my
classes on time
children you know you ain't gonna work
out i will this is important
fine here hold these
now keep your back straight and bend
your knees like this
[Music]
so
dad you're a football coach do you use
human growth hormone to enhance the
performance of your players
we lost our last game 63-9 what do you
think
i think you should look into human
growth hormone and if you do
send some this kid's way with no access
to controlled substances
i was left with only one option missy
will you teach me to ride a bike
tomorrow
why not mom working me mom old
dad fab okay
i'm such a good person
[Music]
foreign